we're going to begin this hour with an
author and an illustrator who's a
favorite among children and the young at
heart that's a lot of us you may not
recognize the name mo willems but
there's a very good chance you're going
to recognize this guy's work willems who
began his career as a writer and
animator for sesame street that's a good
way to start has created a series of
memorable characters like elephant and
piggy the naked mole rat and who
cannot forget canufel bunny these days
willems is pouring most of his creative
energy into his very first picture book
character the pigeon jamie wax recently
caught up with him in new york's coney
island to talk about this new book and
why he's throwing that always passionate
bird to pigeon for a bit
[Applause]
what do you think should we uh you
should be riding you're gonna come on
with me as we learned recently in coney
island
let me think about this you got to give
me a moment okay author mo willems isn't
a fan of roller coasters
but one of his characters is
a character so beloved the brooklyn
cyclones recently dedicated a game night
to the pigeon
no not that pigeon this one
it was a celebration of mo willem's
latest book the pigeon will ride the
roller coaster every single type of
animal or character has been covered in
children's storytelling right how did
you land on a pigeon well the pigeon is
the only character that came fully
formed i moved to oxford england for a
month or so to write the great american
picture book i sat there and i wrote and
i wrote and i wrote important meaningful
stories and this pigeon popped up in my
notebook saying don't write about this
it's terrible right about me i'm awesome
so i wrote this idea about a kid trying
to stop the pigeon from driving the bus
and the pigeon said what do you need
this kid for i don't need a co-star
let me start and star he has since his
debut and don't let the pigeon drive the
bus nearly two decades ago the excitable
bird has found his way into the pages of
willem's 67 children's books alongside
much-loved characters like canufflebunny
the elephant gerald and his friend piggy
all your books feel deeply personal and
deeply in the moment you create them but
i wonder how much the pigeon is really
you i
aspire to pigginess
i'm approaching geraldness
and i hope i have left the pigeon behind
okay
that might be my favorite mo williams
quote ever
i can see it now
in all of its role or coastery glory
what i really loved is in the evolution
of the pigeon books they became less
about telling all the rest of us what to
do with the pigeon telling the pigeon
you have to do something you don't want
to do like pitching has to go to school
that's right pigeon will ride that
roller coaster right behind you
every pigeon book is
that wants
needs has to
will
can't it's all of these sort of
imposed verbs
on his life like everything becomes a
theme on that i will need a ticket
but i will have a ticket from the first
time i discovered you as a children's
author it feels as though you're getting
more and more
direct and economical in your
storytelling
my job i feel very strongly is to do 49
of the work
i'm creating the scaffolding for the
kids and the adults to put in the
performance to put in the meaning to put
in the ideas
my job is to write
incomprehensible books for illiterates
you're speaking my language so
because then you bring something in i'm
in a dialogue what i want for the
grown-ups is to have a shame ectomy i
actually want you to be silly because
you're my orchestra particularly with
the littles
you you are the wall between the story
and them because they can't read yet
having children one of the blessings is
remind you that you can be ridiculous
[Music]
and while willem's blend of ridiculous
yet profound storytelling now extends
well beyond the page the message remains
the same true story why do you think
you've been so successful at translating
your work
to visual mediums i
respect the audience
and i gravitate to projects that terrify
me
because that's the excitement of it
let me drive the box i think some people
want their books to be read i want my
books to be sparks does that make you
perform does that make you sing does it
make you draw a book is not meant to be
read it's meant to be read a billion
times and it's meant to create a new
environment for kids and grown-ups to
create
what a what a fun day at coney island
with that guy about him jamie i like
gravitate to things that terrify him in
copper incomprehensible books for
illiterates and i aspire to pigginess i
love his personality and the way that he
thinks you know he has experiences i
mean he really when i met him i felt
like i was meeting someone my children
knew and that i knew because his books
are as important in the spaces between
the drawings and the words as they are
in the drawings and the words their
experiences he's so right though parents
as you perform for your little ones when
you read that goodnight story you are
half author of the book no doubt when
they get complicated there's a lot of
words on the page you're skipping
through and condensing and jumping ahead
skipping a page oh gosh yeah right
that is a major milestone look we're
going to have people notice when you
skip a page we're going to have books
for luca and eloise and little jamie
duttier who's on the way
that's my suggestion
yep she's coming yeah
i love that i like i was awesome
thank you perfect